pivotal moment in a dispute that has
divided the NHS
56 of GMB members have voted to accept
the pay offer it's a result that means
the majority of NHS staff Council unions
have agreed to a 5 pay increase and a
lump sum payment offered by the
government for GMB the current dispute
over last year's pay is now over it
means our members can return to work and
we will be urging the government that if
this vote is carried at the staff
Council next week the arrangements are
made to immediately pay that money to
get that money into our members pockets
but the offer has left unions divided
while Unison and GMB now want the deal
implemented RCN and unite have rejected
it and say they will continue to strike
that will not stop us taking action to
win a fair deal for our members but look
this is also about the future of the NHS
itself 133
000 vacancies in England alone this pay
deal goes nowhere near to dealing uh
with that Great Ormond Street Children's
Hospital has warned a walkout by nurses
that starts on Sunday has left them with
difficult decisions about the care they
can provide
Saint Thomas's Hospital in central
London is warning that its a e service
will also be significantly impacted
critical care nurse Dave Reese will be
among those on the picket line I'd like
to see my union unite combined with the
doctors Union the BMA and the nurses
Union the RCN and take Joint action
Health secretary Steve Barkley welcomed
gmb's announcements and says he's
hopeful other unions will now formally
accept the payoffer the NHS staff
Council will meet on Tuesday it uses an
electoral system and this GMB result
means that the number of unions who want
to see the government's payoffer
implemented is now in the majority but
this won't see an end to the strikes
unite and the RCN say they will continue
to fight but the impact of any possible
action they take will not be the same as
earlier strikes and that will be a
relief for thousands of waiting patients
Ashish Joshi Sky News in central London